we spent a lot of time talking about the
left around here but this week we're
gonna be diving into the right my guest
is conservative radio talk show host
lawyer and writer larry elder larry has
written several books on conservative
principles with a focus on government
and racial issues much of his work is
very similar actually to the ideas we
talk about here on the Rubin report
including religion the role of
government and personal responsibility
according to his biography Larry uses
facts and common sense to arrive at his
conclusions that sounds familiar right
now if I use those same precepts as a
liberal can we both be right at the same
time could both be wrong is the answer
somewhere in the middle well that's
exactly what we're gonna try to find out
as I discuss with Don Lemon last week
the media talks so much about the
left-right divide in this country that
it's easy to forget that there are
decent people on both sides of the
debate this is one of the reasons I've
taken the left to task so much on this
show the further off the deep-end they
go the less will be able to find
compromise with people we disagree with
just because I may have different views
on abortion than Republicans doesn't
mean that they hate all women just
because I may have different views than
Republicans on guns doesn't mean that
they're a bunch of rednecks and just
because Republicans aren't for
legalizing marijuana doesn't mean they
aren't fun to hang out with all right
well that one might be true but I think
you see my point
maybe the best way to start a
conversation about political ideology is
to actually define the terms this is
something I've done with the few guests
so far because I often think we're all
talking about different things while
using the same words fear not I have
Google and according to the oxford
dictionary here's the definition of
conservatism conservatism is the holding
of conservative principles the tendency
to resist great or sudden change
especially in politics adherence to
traditional values and ideas sometimes
opposed to liberalism
all right so I think we have a nice
jumping-off point they're basically
conservatives aren't big on change and
when they are they want to go about it
slowly I think this concept has been
conflated with the concept of right-wing
politics so I even googled that
according to the concise Oxford
dictionary of politics in liberal
democracies the political right opposes
socialism and social democracy
right-wing parties include conservatives
Christian Democrats classic liberals
nationalists and the far-right racists
and fascists you can see how these two
concepts have morphed into the
Republican Party in America we have an
ideology that doesn't want to change the
system too quickly
coupled with a political affiliation
that is focused on economics and some
level of moral authority interestingly
classical liberals are also included in
that group and the more and more I've
been talking about this stuff the more
I've been considering myself in that
category I'm gonna touch on that more in
the next couple weeks now that we've
laid out some basic terms I think we
have a solid jumping-off point to
discuss all the issues of the day from
abortion to economics to foreign policy
to guns can we find out where we agree
instead of just yelling over each other
I think we can but the only way is to be
brave enough to talk to those we don't
actually agree with if we refuse to talk
to those that we don't see eye-to-eye
with we'll just end up taking an
eye-for-an-eye
my guest this week is a lawyer a writer
and host of the aptly named larry elder
radio show Larry how's it going well
great Dave thank you for having me I
appreciate it yeah thanks for coming in
I've been trying to make this happen
with you for a while aren't you tossing
you forever caught up with me you've
been in this studio before I have I've
guest hosted for Larry a couple times
Larry King that hurricane that's that's
a Larry man yeah he has the thing it is
kind of for the full hour yeah you can
only have people with the name Larry
that's right I guess so storms did that
work out for you so there's a lot of
stuff I want to talk about and then in
the beginning of the show I set up that
I am a liberal you're a conservative I
can do insist that by the time this show
is over we can move you to the center a
little bit and maybe by the time the
show is over week it's not gonna but
that's what it's all about that's why
I've wanted to have you on the show
because I find there were some people in
the public space that I disagree with
but that I'd like to sit down and talk
about some of the ideas and and I
consider you in that in appreciate but
before we get to the politics I like the
audience to know a little bit about the
history of the people I'm talking about
so can you just I know you were born in
LA right
give me a little larry elder history
just wanna race in LA my dad was a
janitor he cleaned toilets my dad was
born in Athens Georgia didn't know who
the mother is I doesn't know what those
father is rather my name elder was the
name of some dude who was in his life
the longest my father was kicked out of
his house in 13 years old by his
irresponsible grandmother and was on his
own from that point on my mom grew up on
a farm kind of aristocracy for a black
woman she owned the farm they owned the
farm anyway my dad and my mom got
together and moved to California in the
40s I have two brothers I am as you
mentioned the lawyer born and raised in
LA and went to college in the East Coast
law school in the Midwest stayed in Ohio
for about 17 years came back to LA about
22 years ago got into TV and radio and
I've been doing it ever since there you
go alright so now we got we got the meet
what do you do now you're not a
practicing lawyer right negative no no I
did it for two and a half three years
and that was it I find a lot of people
in the public space either were lawyers
at one time or I know there's a ton of
comedians that were lawyers what is it
about lawyers a lot of them want to get
out what's that I'm not sure that's true
it's just a real flexible thing to do
you learn how to reason you learn about
the law you learn about the Constitution
if you're a trial lawyer you learn how
to think on your feet and it lends
itself to doing other things
but most people I know who went to law
school at least the ones I went to law
school with stayed in the law yeah so is
that a perfect segue to get you to be
someone that talks for a living right
like instead of having to litigate it in
the courtroom you could litigate it on
air and bounce back and forth with
people and that's right although most
lawyers are not trial lawyers it's kind
of the image of most lawyers is that
they're glib and fast most lawyers sit
behind a desk and fill out papers there
they're tax lawyers or or constitutional
lawyers or contract lawyers or something
like that only about 10% of lawyers end
up going to becoming litigators and even
a smaller number of those actually try
cases yeah all right so now let's talk
about conservatism hmm let's do it so
I've mostly been calling out the left on
my show because I consider myself part
of the left right and I've seen the left
sort of really go off the deep end to
the left and I haven't been happy about
it so I haven't talked that much about
the
right I've had a couple people on the
right so first off how would you define
conservatism what do you think that even
means at this point in America in 2016
what is it considered well I don't mind
being called a conservative I'm sorry
but I said to be a four-letter word but
I really call myself a libertarian I
believe in article 1 section 8 of the
Constitution which gives the federal
government a small number of things to
do Dave meant money put together an army
deal with the border is a handful of
other things that's it
welfare healthcare abortion same-sex
marriage doctor sister suicide all the
social issues that the Supreme Court
takes up in my view they shouldn't take
up in the first place that should be
happened done on a state-by-state basis
that's what I think most conservatives
believe as well so I'm with you on a lot
of that and I definitely have some
libertarian beliefs myself I think most
people are libertarian they just don't
know it the founding fathers were
libertarians the founding fathers
drafted a document that said our rights
come from a power other than individuals
and government doesn't give us our
rights we give government our rights and
power and everything else should be left
to the states and the individual so
that's how the Constitution would start
it that's how the country was started
and I think that's how most Americans
really feel when they really think about
it well that's one of the funny things
to me and why I've defended somebody
like Rand Paul who's a lot of people
would say as a liberal I shouldn't be
defending he's a libertarian but he's a
libertarian so on issues such as
legalizing marijuana or gay marriage a
libertarian because you don't want the
government in your bedroom you shouldn't
care about threats issues and as a
liberal I want people to do what they
want and marry who they want so that's
somewhere where a libertarian and a
liberal can really sort of join together
right I think so however you have people
like Bill Maher running around calling
himself a libertarian Bill Maher is not
a libertarian he believes in higher
taxes he believes in a minimum wage
he supported Ralph Nader for for
government who wants to take over
businesses and have government run them
so a lot of people use it because it's a
sexy kind of term and have no idea what
it is right so that's the the economic
side of it so you you're sort of he's
liberal on the on the social stuff and
in a way as a conservative you're
actually pretty liberal on the
conservative on the social stuff again I
believe that same-sex marriage
doctor assisted suicide all these kinds
of things abortion should be done in a
state-by-state basis in California we
had two opportunities to vote for or
against same-sex marriage proposition 30
and another time when we voted on I
think was called issue 8 a measure 8 and
in both cases I voted in favor of
same-sex marriage in both cases I was
overruled I have no problem with the
idea that the majority of my fellow
Americans or fellow Californians did not
agree with me I don't believe that I
then go to the Supreme Court and cram it
down the throats of the other states
right ok so then that's that's the
states rights issue and and sort of so
you would say that the Supreme Court is
legislating from the bench or something
to that effect yeah I would yeah and
that so so you're basically okay with
what happened you just don't like how it
had
yeah so someone like Rand Paul because
it sounds like you have a lot are you
supporting no I'm not you're not I don't
know I don't like Rand Paul because of
his position on foreign affairs and
defense a lot of libertarians and I
don't think being a libertarian leads
you to being an isolationist although
most libertarians are reasons that I
think are kind of confusing but Rand
Paul is one of those guys who attacked
George W Bush for the Iraq war I think
we were justified in going there I think
that the reason for going there were
legitimate and I think a lot of liberals
are hypocritical on this issue too you
talked about how you you chastise people
on the left for being hypocrites I'll
give you one big one the argument
against the Iraq war is that George W
Bush foolishly
wanted to impose our values on another
another culture had no idea what the
aftermath would be if we could rid of
this bad guy right however Obama comes
into office he joins with the British
and the French and bombing Libya getting
rid of Qaddafi why did he threaten us no
they did so for humanitarian civil
rights reasons Hillary recently at a
debate was asked about why she did that
she said well they so they could have
free elections where was the left a same
thing with regard to to Egypt we get rid
of Mubarak he was a thug but they're all
thugs the brother Muslim Brotherhood
comes in there and Obama backs them and
and the country's worse than it was
before same thing and then a senator now
backing the guy that took over right the
moment then Assad for reasons that
escaped me Obama decided or saw it had
to go yeah
why these these countries did not
threaten us the way in my opinion Iraq
did Iraq was a deal after the after 9/11
90% of the American people believe that
we're going to get hit again and this
guy was was stealing from the
oil-for-food program he was he was
interfering with our patrolling the
southern no-fly zones he had used
chemical weapons on his own people we
know that because he used him on the
Iranians he used them on the Kurds he
tried to assassinate George Herbert
Walker Bush he was a threat and like it
or not at least we had a legitimate
reason for going there and he got the
backing of both the house and and the
Senate Obama did did did Egypt and he
did Libya and he did a Syria without the
backing of Congress and yet the left
didn't say a damn thing right sue
Perkins yeah so I'm with you on the
hypocrite mark because I listen I was
there's plenty of video I was against
the Libya thing because at the very
least at the very very least if we're
gonna have a military action we should
have congressional approval right so
then instead of calling it a war they
called it a kinetic military action well
and beyond that Libya did not pose a
threat to us he had no WMD because he
gave them up after we went into the war
in Iraq he was scared bleep less he gave
up the WMD not the United Nations he
gave it to us if they're under lock and
key in Tennessee as we speak so what was
the rationale and where was the left the
same people yelling and screaming about
George W Bush and Dick Cheney and
neo-cons and a nation-building where
were they they didn't say anything it's
hypocritical yeah
well listen we don't have congressional
authorization right now so I would
assume by a lot of standards on the left
Obama is probably a neocon to them right
if they were if they were being
consistent but they're not so but what
was the actual threat I mean so I'm with
you on some of this in terms of that we
all sort of pick our sides and then
chart our values suddenly change
depending on who's in power but what do
you think your principles you don't do
that and I write myself to be principled
I I consider myself to be principled as
well so everything that I've said in the
past related all the stuff still still
sand tough but what was the actual
threat from Iraq look I know that that
Saddam did horrible things and you've
laid out a couple of them but what was
the actual threat george w bush properly
said that they were a grave and gay
during danger after 9/11 90% of the
American people thought we were gonna
get hit again and thought the hit was
gonna be bigger than 9/11 so George W
Bush looks around and says where are the
threats we were still technically at war
against Saddam Hussein we went to war
against him in 1991 and he promised to
fully and thoroughly declare his
chemical and biological weapons he
failed to do so he violated resolution
after resolution after resolution and we
feared that he would either use him
himself or give them to a terrorist and
use them against us and make 9/11 look
like a picnic that was a threat we gave
him 15 months to turn over the stuff and
he refused to do it
Bush went to the night that it did turn
out that there were no nuclear weapons
of mass destruction I disagree with that
as well I believe the weapons were there
we gave him 15 months to thoroughly
declare what he did in that 15 months in
my opinion he got rid of it and I'm not
the only person that said that Dave the
the National Intelligence director our
top spy his name is James clapper he's
in office right now under Obama has
publicly said he believes that Saddam
was saying did in fact have stockpiles
of WMD got rid of them in the during the
15 months run-up to the war the Israeli
Mossad feels the same way and there's
several other American officials that
have said that so I don't believe George
W Bush got the intelligence wrong we
have 16 intelligence agencies all 16
said at the highest level of probability
that Saddam Hussein has stockpiles of
chemical and biological weapons Obama
had the same CIA director who served
under Bill Clinton George Tenet
he said the likelihood that Saddam
Hussein had chemical weapons and
biological weapons was a slam dunk and
the same people that called George W
Bush a [ __ ] won him wanted him to go so
all 16 you guys say that he's got this
stuff and you save got it George I just
not feeling it so I'm not gonna do it
but he's a [ __ ] so when you say that
this is one of the cases that part of
the problem and I think this is a
through line through everything we're
gonna discuss for the next hour is that
I don't know who to believe anymore
that's become a thing so James clapper
he just met right he's the same guy the
same CIA director who sat in front of
Congress and said that we're not spying
on Americans remember and he was
scratching the top of his head because
as they say in Seinfeld when you're
lying you touch the higher up you touch
on your face the bigger the lie is right
a nice guy and he says we're not
wittingly spying on the American public
we now know that that was what he said
when I gave the least untruthful answer
I could give but later on he admitted
and so to me as far as I'm concerned
he's oh he's legitimately honest guy
well I guess he gave the least honest
answer he least untruthful and least
untruthful right but it wasn't I guess I
guess but it wasn't truthful well it was
classified yeah it was classified he
wasn't opposed to talk about it all
right so without without getting too
caught up in the words though but do you
think that's part of the problem that we
just don't know who to believe anymore
no I believe our government officials we
barely believe the media well I have my
own issues with government but it might
think my problem with the Iraq war is
that Republicans failed to say what I've
said and defend it even Jeb Bush has not
defended it properly he was asked when
he first started running what do you
think about the Iraq war well I well I
mean honestly if you can't even defend
what your brother did how can other
people do it so I think Americans have
forgotten why we went there at one time
73% of the American people supported
this war you have to remind people that
why you why you've gone to war might be
what the reasons are and people have
forgotten and now they have this vague
idea that George W Bush overreacted and
went in there and posed somebody because
he just didn't like him and that's why
we were there and let's not do that
anymore that's kind of how people have
given the Cliff Notes version of what
happened and it's unfair so what would
you say to the people that would argue
that Isis it wouldn't exist right now if
we hadn't toppled Saddam because he at
least had for all the horrible things he
was doing and the bath party was doing
terrible things and they were executing
people and throwing gays off roofs and
you know using mustard gas on the Kurds
and all that stuff but at least he was
keeping a sort of lid on the actual
craziness that we're seeing right now my
my problem with that is that we don't
know what's that I'm just saying would
have done had we not gone there even
though we didn't find the stockpiles
there were two people that George W Bush
sent to find the stockpiles one was
named David K the other was named Chuck
Topher both of them said we didn't find
any stockpiles we screwed up however
this guy was going to reconstitute his
WMD program and reconstitute his nuclear
program when the heat was off so we
would've had to deal with him anyway the
second thing I say is that President
Obama pulled out all the troops because
he ran in 2008 and said the Iraq war was
a dumb war we never should have gone
there over the advice of Hillary his
Secretary of State over the advice of
his then Secretary of Defense
leon panetta over the advice of his
former Secretary of Defense Robert Gates
over the advice of the Joint Chiefs he
pulled out all the troops he was warned
if you do this there'll be a vacuum he
did it anyway
Ray Odierno is a member of the Joint
Chiefs he just retired and he gave us
speech when he retired and he was asked
if he does he believe that we should
have left people there he said yes have
we done so I said who could have been
dealt with so in my opinion however you
feel about it when Obama walked in and
heritage this mess yeah he should have
made it better it not worse he made it
worse so in a way you're so you're sort
of blaming both sides right in that in
that or I guess I would blame both sigh
don't put words in your mouth I would
blame both sides hearing that we went to
the wrong war and then by Obama leaving
the way he did even though most of the
Americans very clearly didn't want to be
there anymore and when he ran for
president seven years ago that his whole
thing was we're gonna get out as soon as
possible but that then created the the
breeding ground for this because we
didn't leave in a in a sword I'll go
half way with you yeah we didn't go into
the wrong war went to the right war for
the right reasons
I think the intelligence was good and I
think the problem was when Obama came in
he wanted to get out so quickly that he
did not realize what the aftermath would
be and I'm not the only one who said
this Robert Hayes written a book
scathing attack the most scathing attack
on a sitting commander-in-chief by a
former member of cabinet member I have
ever read and he even recently if the
few days ago Dave said that Obama's
national security and foreign policy
advisors are dangerously naive they see
the world through this prism that they
want which is why the Benghazi thing
happened the reason the McCarthy thing
happened as Obama is running in 2012 GM
is dead GM is alive Osama bin Laden is
dead and al Qaeda is on the run
therefore Benghazi was not thoroughly
defended because they thought that the
Libyans were happy with us because we
got rid of Gaddafi yeah and so he states
they in my opinion the Obama
administration sees the world through
their a prism of this ridiculous idea
that if we are nicer to people and reach
out with an unclench fist they will
reach out in kind the world doesn't work
that way we have bad people who hate us
and we need to deal with it right so I'm
with you on that part for sure because
look if you think back the big speech
that Obama gave in Cairo
which was that everyone said yeah this
is the reset this is that we're gonna be
different and we're gonna try to deal
with people and we did that's with bombs
more with discussion I mean the Middle
East especially but most of the world
we've we're more in more of a precarious
place now then I don't think any part of
the world is better off with Obama n and
I think that you look at polls now
George W Bush left office in the in the
low 30s I don't think any president has
been that unpopular in my lifetime you
look at polls now more people like
George W Bush didn't like Obama Obama's
rating is at 45% Bill Clinton's at this
juncture in the seventh year of his turn
he was at 65% most American believer on
the wrong track economically and most
American believer on the wrong track in
terms of foreign policy yeah all right
so I don't want to get too lost in just
foreign policy so last thing on this is
a lot of what you're saying sort of
sounds like neoconservative stuff to me
is there can you be a libertarian and a
neoconservative I mean I know this is
what you're getting for it this is sort
of why you don't like Rand Paul but do
those things seem like they have nothing
to do with each other and yet I know
that there's a lot of people that do
sort of get what you're what you're
saying well the term neoconservatism to
me is a four-letter word is a term that
people invent to to malign somebody's
position I see the world realistically I
think we have enemies we need to deal
with them I did not believe as you did
just now pointed out that we should have
gone to war in in Libya I don't believe
in doing anything unless this is
consistent with our national security
interests when Jimmy Carter for example
through the Shah of Iran under the bus
in the 70s what was that all about he
did it because he wanted freedom he
wanted to liberate the people who were
behind bars the same people we now call
terrorists these are the ones that Obama
forced the Shah to let out of prison and
they ultimately toppled the regime
what's that all about it's not our job
to impose them democracy is our job to
make sure that countries are are not our
enemies our countries are doing things
they're consistent with our own national
security interest and that and that's my
problem right so you don't want a nation
bill do you want to do things that you
consider sort of defensive posture
correct we went into Haiti I think
during Bill Clinton's administration
because they were having difficulty it's
not our job I want to get this right so
I want to look at my notes for this
according to this you are black correct
that is correct
not african-american that's not a term I
like you how come you don't like the
term man ridiculous I was born and
raised in America I've never been to
Africa why am i an African American most
of my people have been here longer than
most of others the other people in this
room yet most people don't have a - you
know I'm an italian-american Greek
American Romanian American it's an
absurd term it's a term that Jesse
Jackson almost single-handedly crammed
down the throats of our media and after
Jackson began to talk about why blacks
should have some connection to Africa
all of a sudden New York Times LA Times
all of the media began using that
expression it's thick ulis yeah I mean I
personally don't use the term
african-american that much because one
time I had a guest on the show and I
referred to her as African American she
said well I'm actually Jamaican so you
know you mean so I guess that that goes
to your point it's all right and I
remember reading one time Dave somebody
was given a description of some suspect
who had done some crime was running away
and he was described as an African
American how do you know where he was
from could've been from Africa come in
from Jamaica it could be from Canada so
what do you make of that when someone
like because I know you really rail
against Jesse Jackson and and these guys
on the left that use and I want to talk
a lot about identity politics okay so
the guys that use these phrases what
what are they going for there well
they're whatare goal that the goal is to
tell black people that were victims that
discrimination and racism remain major
problems in America when in fact they
don't and they want black people to vote
for the Democratic Party the Democratic
Party gets ninety five percent of the
black vote and the reason they get it is
because blacks are convinced that the
number one issue facing the country
right now is social justice racist white
cops discrimination systemic racism
microaggression whatever a new word they
come up with and it's a bunch of
nonsense a number one problem
domestically faced in this country is a
breakdown of the family and President
Obama said it I didn't a black kid or
our kid not just a black kid a kid
raised without a dad is five times more
likely to be poor and commit crimes nine
times more likely to drop out of school
and 20 times more likely to end up in
jail so you're far more likely to end up
in jail without having a dad than you
are because of a white racist cop right
so but you wouldn't not acknowledge that
there are some
systemic issues give me an example tell
me what you think the most systemic
racist issue is what is it well I would
say that because black people in most
cases in many cases were descendants of
slaves that racism as a as an
institution that it just 2000 amount of
it just exists i 2015 that give me the
most blatant racist example you can come
up with right now I think you could
probably find evidence that in general
cops are that cops are more willing to
shoot if the perpetrator is black what's
your date of end white what's your basis
for saying that last year though look I
know a lot of people would say look
what's going on I know what they would
say I'm talking about what the facts are
965 people were shot by cops last last
year and killed four percent of them
were white cops shooting unarmed blacks
in in Chicago in 2011 21 people were
shot and killed by cops in 2015 there
were seven in Chicago which is a third
black a third white and third Hispanic
70% of the homicides are black on black
about 40 per month almost 500 in the per
year last year in Chicago and 75% of
them are unsolved where is the black
lives matter on that the idea that a
racist white cop and shooting unarmed
black people is apparel to black people
is BS it's complete and total BS and and
the reason for these so-called activists
saying this is the assumption that
racism remains a major problem in
America the media CNN especially MSNBC
runs down whenever a black cop shoots
somebody and in and it's a some some
march on Washington it's ridiculous
black people half the homicides in this
country are committed by and against
black people last year there were 14,000
homicides not talking about suicides I'm
talking about homicides half of them
were black 96% of them black on black of
that 7,000 wears a black black lives
matter people on that so that there's
where you would say that this is purely
because of social justice this you're
purely because they want ultimately for
people to be angry enough to just keep
voting Democrat that's right and where's
where's the evidence of a lack of social
justice when a black suspect is killed
by by a cop
believe me the media is on it people are
watching it and
and justice will will for the most part
occur in Baltimore where Freddie gray
was killed Freddie gray died in a van I
shouldn't say was killed died in a van
yeah you have a city that's 45% black
City Council is 100% Democrat the
majority of City Council is black the
top cop at the time was with black the
number two cop with black the majority
of the command staff is black the the
mayor is black the AG is black and yet
here we are talking about racism I mean
it's it's absurd
yeah absurd so it's funny I find myself
caught in between this a little bit as a
liberal where I want to always try to
defend the other so in this case the
other being black people I'm always
sympathetic to that and they yeah yeah
at the same time I hear you laying out a
pretty solid well just the facts say
something else too there was just a
study University of Washington and it
turns out cops were more reluctant more
hesitant to pull the trigger against the
black black suspect than a white suspect
probably because of the fear of being
accused of racially profiling and the
fear that the Civil Rights established
was going to come down on him so if
anything whites are more likely to be
shot by a cop under under certain
circumstances than a than a black person
and in last 30 or 40 years the number of
percentage of suspects killed by cops
who are black has declined 75% however
the percentage of whites killed by cops
has flatlined yeah and so if anything
people are more concerned about shooting
black people for fear that they're gonna
be called racist and almost all every
one of these incidents whether it's Eric
Gardner in in New York who died because
he was selling loosies and resisted
arrest
whether it's Tamir rice in Cleveland who
hit was twirling around the gun whether
it's Michael Brown in Ferguson who had
just committed an art strong-armed
robbery
almost every one of these incidents
involves somebody resisting arrest why
don't you just do what the police tell
you my dad said when I get pulled over
have my hand at ten o'clock have my hand
at two o'clock say yes sir say no sir
make sure my paperwork is in order and
if I feel the cop is mistreating me get
a badge number and deal with it later on
if Jesse Jackson and Al Sharpton and
Obama and the whole group of them told
black people to do that we'd have a lot
fewer of these things to deal with in
the first place yeah
all right so I'm with ya I'm hearing a
lot of what you're saying in here so as
a black conservative then who now you've
you've laid out your case there but you
haven't laid out yours I I asked you to
name the most important example of
racism and you gave white cops going
after black people and I and I told you
gave you the facts for that so that's
nonsense so what you must have something
else what else is it if you think racism
remains a problem in America give it to
well I think it remains a problem not it
even some it may not be systemic in that
we have it's not like you're not being
hired because you're black there's no
systemic reason you no legal reason that
that exists that kind of thing but I
think that racism as a general I need
fury I need this I need some specific
sorry you gave me the white cop thing
what else give me another example what
you think is a problem well well as a
black conservative tell me how to know
you how do you get people to come around
you're the one who made the assertion
that yeah racism remains a major problem
in America I asked you to give me an
example you gave me white cops going
after blacks I as far as I'm concerned
you didn't hold it up very well what's
the other argument you have what's the
other thing
well I don't know that it's systemic in
that in the sort of macro set I don't
know what it is you're talking no no I
believe me that's a hundred likes are
not getting into school bs that we have
a race we have affirmative action so a
black person with it with an SAT and a
GPA of X will get into a school faster
and easier than the right person with an
SAT or a GPA of X and if going to going
to school there's a route to the middle
class you can make an argument that
blacks have an easier route to middle to
the middle class if you're talking about
blacks about poverty the poorer you are
the more accessible loans and grants are
for you the the problem the biggest
burden that black people have in my
opinion again is the percentage of
blacks 75% of them that are raised
without fathers and that has every other
social negative consequences connected
to it crime not being able to compete
economically in the country being more
likely to be arrested that's the number
one problem facing the black community
and when I hear people tell me about
systemic racism or unconscious racism I
always say give me an example and almost
nobody can do it so so the families
I'll follow your logic they're on family
stuff what can actually be done about
that then I mean what because that's a
big reverse to welfare state in 1890
1900 you look at census reports a black
kid believe it or not was slightly more
likely to be born to a nuclear intact
family than a white kid even during
slavery a black kid was more likely to
be born under a roof with his biological
mother and biological father than today
what's happened is we launched this
so-called war on poverty in the 60s
we're literally Lyndon Johnson sent
people knocking on doors and I lived in
the 60s and people knocked on doors
uprising women of their availability to
welfare provided there was no man in the
house and we went from 25% of blacks
being born outside of wedlock in 65 to
75% right now and you look at how much
money that we spent on welfare and the
lines are parallel
it was a neutron bomb dropped on this
country not just in the black community
but on people in general at one time
only about 5% of whites were born
outside of wedlock now 25% of whites are
born outside of wedlock I was in college
in 1970 and there was a report called
the Moynihan report the Negro family a
case for national actions written by
liberal by a man who became a Democratic
senator for the firm from New York and
at the time 25% of black kids were born
outside of wedlock he said my god this
number is is horrific if we don't do
something about it it could get even
higher well fast forward 25% a white
kids are now born outside of wedlock it
is the number one problem in this
country and what we've done in my
opinion is we economically incentivize
women to marry the government we've
allowed men to abandon their financial
and more responsibility and now we have
this so the left has done this right ok
so do you think then that as a black
conservative that the biggest issue is
it's impossible to have this
conversation right right like the stuff
we're talking about right now is rarely
really discussed in the media you know
people you've written some books about
it and people talk about it every now
and again but we rarely have this
discussion because and this is where I
will agree with you that the left has
made language such a problem and
everyone's so trigger warned and safe
space that were afraid that if you have
this conversation that somehow I'm gonna
come off racist you know you know or
that's not what
the conversation we'd have the
conversation because the left would then
have to look in the mirror and go jesus
H Christ look look at what I've done and
they don't want to do this I've had a
radio show for almost 25 years I've
invited Jesse Jackson on 50 times 60
times I've invited I'll sharpen on that
that number Maxine Waters another
loudmouth black woman around here who's
running around talking about racism she
won't come on my show either they don't
want to deal with these issues why let's
have a conversation if I'm wrong tell me
I'm wrong tell me how I'm wrong give me
your data give me your facts tell me
what you got yeah and I could quote the
the Brookings Institution which is a
liberal think tank and the Heritage
Foundation which the conservative think
tank and they'll both tell you that
there there's a relationship between
crime and bad schools and going to
prison and not having a dad so this is
not just a liberal kind of thing or a
conservative kind of thing it's a real
world kind of thing and they don't want
to have that conversation I've never
heard a reporter asked Obama about the
connection between the rise of the of
the single-parent household and the rise
of welfare spending I've never heard
anybody ask him that question not one
time yeah and so as far as I'm concerned
this is this is desire not to have this
conversation for fear that it then will
cause you to rethink your assumptions a
psychologist will call that cognitive
dissonance the this this anxiety that
you feel when you have had your
assumptions challenged and you don't
want to do it it's uncomfortable yeah so
how then would someone like you or
someone that believes in what the things
that you're talking about how do you
wrestle away a little bit of the
narrative from the black lives matter
folks because obviously you tell I tell
the truth they're about the same thing
course I do I care I tell the truth I
talk about the number one cause of
preventable death for young white men is
car accidents the number one cause of
preventable death for young black man is
homicide committed by other young black
men I tell the truth I give the facts
and the facts are racist yes take facts
are racist right so you know I'm friends
with another black conservative David
Webb you probably know on Sirius XM and
he's a Fox News contributor and I had
been doing a progressive show a while
back and I was on with someone and they
didn't know him personally nor knew that
I was friends with him right and they
kept saying he's the token black eye
right now I'm sure you get plenty oh my
goodness token bootlicker Uncle Tom
[ __ ] [ __ ] Tom coconut as in brown on
the outside white on the inside
Oreo same concept the Antichrist and you
got because they've got to malign
somebody like me I am a bigger threat to
their whole ideology that almost anybody
else a black guy who does not believe
that he's a victim a black guy who
believes in hard work and personal
responsibility a black guy who doesn't
believe in handouts the black guy
doesn't believe in the welfare state a
black guy he doesn't believe in
affirmative action I am the antithesis
of everything they stand for
and therefore I can't just be dealt with
with facts and and rebut it with X I've
got to be maligned I've got to be a
castaway I've got to be treated as as if
I'm Darth Vader that's what the left
does so that's interesting
and again this is where I've really
struggled with my guys on the left
because in a way that is actually
showing it's racist of course it is
right because I don't have the same
right to have an opinion if somebody
else I've never heard rush limbaugh be
called anti white because he criticizes
Hillary in the left but I criticize
black left people and I'm I'm anti black
it's bigotry it's racism calling
somebody an Uncle Tom is as offensive as
calling somebody an n-word lover yeah so
when it comes to to the black community
and politics so I I got you on a bunch
of a bunch of this stuff the black
community in a lot of ways isn't for
some of the things that the Democratic
Party is for right because the black
community a lot of times and it has a
lot to do with the church is more
socially conservative the only thing
that that connects black people to the
Democratic Party in my opinion is this
notion of social justice and this notion
that racism remains a major problem in
America look down the list of things
that black people like and and support
blacks are more pro-life than whites are
blacks were more anti gay marriage then
the whites were that's one of the
reasons its proposition passed here in
California is because of the way blacks
and browns voted again I didn't vote
that way but it's the way a lot of
blacks and browns did blacks want to be
wealthy when the reason Donald Trump is
getting about 25 percent of black which
is five times by the way the percentage
that Mitt Romney got is because of
Donald Trump's swag
and his and his being proud that he's
made money and so and and in the inner
city wait that's really fascinating
little piece right there never one more
quickly important the Democratic Party
is completely beholden to the teachers
union and vice versa the Union is
adamantly opposed to vouchers where the
money follows the kid rather than the
other way around
inner-city black women and fathers
inner-city black brown women and brown
father's want vouchers they realize the
schools suck I went to Crenshaw High
School in South Central right now three
percent that's not a typo three percent
of kids can do math at grade level I'm
gonna send my kid to that school because
I don't have enough money to send my kid
to a better school it's it's it's an
assault there's a program called the DC
hope scholarship program where every
year parents who subscribe to them to
the program and it's four times as many
people want to get in as there are seats
will give kids about 10 to 12 thousand
dollars to go to a non DC government
school and every two years when it's
over Obama and the Democrats trying to
try to shut it down and the reason they
don't is a bunch of black parents go to
the streets have a press conference
start crying and so all my kids doing
better I can't think of anything more
damaging to a kid's future is to send
him to a school where it's a [ __ ] School
where the kids are are not learning
where a lot of them are not learning
because they don't care and where the
whole level is now dumb down to cater to
that lowest common denominator in a
class and as a result you have kids that
have poorer SAT scores and the otherwise
would if they had a chance to go
somewhere else
that challenged them and so inner-city
parents want vouchers young black people
when they're told about the benefits of
privatizing Social Security want to do
it because 65 years old blacks die
sooner than whites do and when you die
all your contribution to Social Security
go poof as opposed to being able to will
it to your child when blacks are taught
about this young blacks want the
opportunity to put their money into a
account that they can control so when
they get 65 years old they have real
money so privatizing Social Security
vouchers
abortion same-sex marriage all of these
issues blacks are really not in lockstep
with a Democratic Party but the
Democratic Party has successfully
convinced blacks that racism this white
cop this is why it spread the man's out
to get you and vote for us and we'll
deal with it so how much of this is a
messaging problem if I grant you all of
that right how much of this is just a
messaging problem by the Republicans
because it seems to me and I've said
this several times but someone like Tim
Scott who is a black Republican senator
right from the south right he should be
a hero not only of the black community
but he should really be a hero of the
left right because this is a successful
well I should be an American hero he
really should be I mean he should some
certainly Ally at the very least be
bigger in the national debate why isn't
he a bigger surrogate for whoever he's
going to support I assume it will be
Republican why is this guy lost in in
this scheme well it's the same reason
that black states vote 95% for the
Democratic Party he's considered to be
an Uncle Tom he's a Republican he's a
black Republican he said he's a he's
some sort of unicorn I don't know what
he is that that's how that's how they
feel so then what do you do what do you
do as a Republican to break this
narrative you know I got it you told the
truth I got it you tell the truth but
obviously there has to be something
bigger than messaging here because well
telling me the numbers 90-95 it's an
uphill fight I mean to me there is a
access of indoctrination you have the
media you have academia you have
Hollywood all of which tell black people
that they're victims most professors are
to the left the media certainly is off
to the left and Holly was to the left
and so you get up and and you're
indoctrinated all the time with things
like social justice inequality the man's
out to get you we need a higher minimum
wage you name the left-wing
a policy and and and you and you pick it
up through osmosis that's why when we
first started the conversation I said I
hope to move you towards the center and
you say I hope to move you towards
towards the towards the center and I say
it's not gonna happen because because I
there's nothing you can tell me I
haven't heard but I probably can say
some things your audience hasn't heard
because LA Times New York Times CNN ABC
NBC CBS new year
times you name it these are all to the
left whatever left-wing position you're
gonna hear it you're gonna hear why how
and where but but the other position you
won't hear unless you watch Fox News or
listen to talk radio and a lot of people
won't do it if you make them if you pay
them right so I hope it's clear in our
40 minutes or so together so far when I
say I'm on the left I consider myself a
classic liberal and that I stand for
liberal principles John Stuart Mill type
liberal exactly exactly that's not a
liberal and and I know in a lot of ways
that that makes you a concern you're a
Jack Kennedy kind of kind of Democrat he
cut taxes right he was a cold warrior he
was he liked hunting he liked the Second
Amendment so doesn't this show you how
stupid the words are so what I did at
the top of the show shows you how the
Democratic Party has evolved to the left
and abandoned principles my mom was a
was a Democrat my mom was a Republican
my dad was Republican all his life and
my mom stopped voting for the Democratic
Party and she said as many people have
said I didn't leave the Democratic Party
they left me she didn't like welfare she
didn't like the idea of rewarding people
just because you had a kid and then
given you more money when had an
additional kid she didn't like any of
all of that right and she started voting
for george w bush her last two election
cycles so it's really ironic that's not
messaging it's the fact that the country
and the country in general has gone to
the left and the Democrats to the to a
greater degree than Republicans have
gone to the left the country has changed
in part in my opinion because of
immigration including illegal
immigration people who are coming to the
country illegally from third-world
countries like Mexico they don't know
what I'm talking about when I talk about
limited government they believe health
care is a right they're taught that in
Mexico they taught that other places and
they come here in America and they pull
that lever for the Democratic Party
which is why in my opinion the left
wants what board is to be porous because
it changes the country page of the
electorate it changes the demographics
the Democratic Party has not won the
white vote since 1964 the more white
people there are in the country the
worst Democrats do the more left-wing
the more people have color there are in
the country the best the left does and
so what incentive is there for them to
to police the borders what incentive is
there for them to shut down sanctuary
cities to stop catch and release there
isn't in my opinion there's been a very
subtle and very diabolical changing of
the mentality of this country by left
people so that a state like California
could never vote for Ronald Reagan as
they did in the past could never vote
for Richard Nixon as they did in the
past you have New York and California
just write them off and there's 10 or 12
states now that we fight over everything
else is now written off it's ridiculous
so at the top of the show when I was
laying out some of the principles that
we're talking about here I saw classical
liberalism falling into the conservative
category as you just said and it's funny
because while I consider myself a
classical liberal and ie can lay out
every liberal principle there is that I
would defend it's it's scary to me
because though because we get so caught
up in words that you know oh I don't
want to be considered a conservative
because I'm a liberal right it's a scary
proposition right well again it's it's
it's about limited government and
personal responsibility as far as I'm
concerned what you've told me is that
you are really somebody on my camp far
more so than somebody on Bernie Sanders
camp
well I'm liberal in that I'm for gay
marriage and I don't mind if you smoke
weed in your bedroom as a general rule I
do like lower taxes but I think we could
have a progressive tax at some level so
we probably disagree a little bit there
I do think you should if you keep making
more and more and especially as you're
getting into the the dozens of millions
and the hundreds of millions yeah we
could have a progressive tax that would
tack the tax those people more I'm not
necessarily for the 90% tax that that
Bernie wants so I you know some of the
economic I wonder let me ask you why is
it that nobody gave Dick Cheney love
because Cheney had a more progressive
position on same-sex marriage than Obama
did when Obama was still but you're
changing all evolving Cheney but Cheney
didn't have until he was out of office
so that's you know it's a little
disingenuous what he did he say he still
years before Obama said he was in favor
of gay marriage said I'm in favor of
allowing states to determine this he
said that years before while he was in
office though I don't think that was
while he was all I know was years before
Obama because when Obama became
president 2008 he's not only said that
he was in favor of traditional marriage
he said God was in the mix all of a
sudden years later God's no longer in
the mix four years ago then got out of
the mix but anyway the point is that
Dick Cheney said that he supported
same-sex marriage on a state-by-state
basis
well before the left did well before
Obama did well before Hillary did got no
love
so isn't actually well that I think
would just go there because politicians
are pandering I mean that I don't know
that that makes Obama any more of a liar
than any other politician I'm talking
about I get you I'm talking about why
somebody didn't give it give Cheney a
couple of Atta boys on that I know that
people on the left hate him called him a
neocon and believe he whispering in
george w bush's ear and got bush to do
all sorts of bad things but I would have
thought on this issue since the less
considered such an important issue
I don't by the way that they would have
not have given Cheney a little bit of
ways you can sit what do you mean you
don't consider same-sex marriage to be
that big of a deal to me it's give
people equality and then let's not to
think about it anymore that would be
fair enough I'm just saying I I think
the number one issue in this country is
self-defense and in the number one
domestic policy issue as I mentioned is
the destruction of the family these
other things same-sex marriage war on
drugs global warming I consider to be
further down the list yes so the war on
drugs you're actually for legalizing
drugs right I'm for the the government
getting out of it both federally and at
the state level yeah and that would and
interestingly this may be a little
boring for your for your viewers though
but in the in the earlier in the 20th
century we had the war against alcohol
the Constitution was amended to fight
the war against alcohol and then it was
a minute again when we decided didn't
work we've had since Richard Nixon this
war on drugs
the Constitution was never amended for
that and I don't understand why people
don't make the argument that it is
illegal what the federal government is
doing because in order to get rid of
alcohol Congress knew that they had to
change the Constitution which they did
there's no power article 1 section 8
that gives the federal government the
authority to wage a war on alcohol or a
war on on on drugs but to do the one in
alcohol they change the Constitution and
then reach Ange it but they never did
that for the war on drugs yeah so how
much of that do you think goes to why
the black family has been affected I
mean when you think about the amount of
black people black men especially and
minorities in general that are in jail
we now
for-profit jails and a huge percentage
of these people are in jail because of
drug offenses
well not that many about 12 to 15
percent but-but-but-but whatever that
seems pretty significant whatever the
percentage is I think the war on drugs
should be rethought and we should deal
with it as a health problem and not a
criminal justice problem but the reason
for the large number of black behind
bars it goes back to what I said earlier
about the breakdown of the black family
and not being taught the right kinds of
values and that has all sorts of other
social consequences including a greater
propensity to commit crime yeah all
right let's back up for a second because
you you quickly said something about
Hollywood and I know I follow you on
twitter and you rail against Hollywood
all I do basically your arguments like
kicking a puppy though yeah I can tell
you know it's not it's not that
difficult right so so just the other
night you know you were you were
tweeting a little bit about the Golden
Globes and the targets that your base
was taking last night I saw you you kept
on CNN Don Lemon who I had on last week
was on the show last week he was talking
about Tavis Smiley and you're not a fan
of Tavis I've known him a long time he's
a he doesn't preach what he practices
wait what he is is a hard-working guy
who came from Indiana with a big poor
family and has done quite well with his
life and instead of telling people bust
your butt do what I did work hard stay
focused it's the man's out to get you
social justice races and racism
everywhere it's nonsense
Hollywood is an easy target because
these guys the Golden Globes they've got
these fine clothing designer clothing
and designer tux and and their jewelry
they're all anti Second Amendment but
they're all protected by armed security
guard and how many of them applied into
a Prius to get to and from the the the
ceremony I mean you're saying very few I
think it's very very not a large number
limos yeah and notice that notice there
were several Bill Cosby jokes I think
three or four Bill Cosby rape jokes not
one Bill Clinton rape joke pourquoi yeah
yeah do you think I mean I'm a firm
believer that a lot of them actually
privately are supporting Republicans or
at least they're voting Republican but
there's this idea that okay we're gonna
go on this you can't sell out you can't
say
name one a list young actor or actress
who's an out of the closet Republican
just one young that means yeah I mean
2030s there you can do it once you're
Clint Eastwood once you're Kelsey
Grammer boy doesn't cut it right no no
but but somebody in his 20s or Jennifer
Lawrence Age star Nate one there's got
to be somebody right
they can't be 100% left-wing but they
will not say so because they know they
won't get parts right and you would say
that's not necessarily because they
believe those things as much as just the
structures in place
it's the bigotry in Hollywood that the
open-minded empathetic people they're
fine as long as you don't say something
that pisses them off yeah and and you
say that you're gonna support Donald
Trump you won't work if you're twenty or
thirty years old you won't work you're
gonna lose jobs yeah so let's talk a
little bit about this and think and
think about that these are these are the
people who are in charge of eighty
percent of what we see on TV and on in
movies and if you come out and you're
twenty or thirty years old and you're a
rising star and you say you know what
listen to Larry oldest show the other
day I think I'm gonna vote Republican
finished done done now now what kind of
power is that to influence the minds of
young people to shape this country
culturally it is massive there was a
book called primetime propaganda by a
young man named Ben Shapiro we're
getting him on the show and and because
he looks so young and looks liberal
whatever that means he was able to get
on the record all these Hollywood
producers people that did Golden Girls
people that did cops and got them on the
record saying I would never hire a
conservative a conservative in this town
will be screwed a conservative in this
town cannot make it I intentionally put
left-wing messages in my fare I tried to
influence culture this way has him all
saying this and has him on tape and the
book came out and it didn't make any
difference
they didn't say I'm sorry I didn't say
we ought to rethink our assumptions he
interviewed Fred Silverman who at one
time as a head of ABC CBS NBC has Fred
Silverman on the record saying a
conservative cannot make it in this town
now if Hollywood has a great impact
on how we think on our culture and you
have this Gestapo essentially shutting
out people who are conservative what
does that say it's scary too frightening
to me yeah well messaging messaging is
everything which actually brings this
back to what you said about Trump before
which I think is sort of fascinating
that he's polling better with the black
community yes because he has this sense
of swagger which I think you could
probably relate directly back to you
know rap music and stuff like that these
guys aren't they're not ashamed of their
success and that so in a weird way Trump
is sort of doing the exact same the
exact thing that you want to happen I
agree but I think there's another big
reason that Trump is scoring with black
people one of the most under polled
things in this country is how black
people are pissed off about illegal
immigration when I was younger there was
a movie that came out of the 70s called
car wash mm-hmm Richard Pryor was in it
yeah and George George Carlin was in it
and it was about a day in the life of
this car wash in South Central not too
far from where I grew up virtually all
the employees were black I defy you to
go to a car wash in South Central now
and see any any employee who's black
illegal immigrants that come over and
taken over this business and black
people see it and they and they realize
it and they are angry about it
and the Democratic Party however because
of what I said earlier about trying to
shift the electorate to the left has in
my opinion thrown blacks under the bus
on this issue and a lot of blacks who
are aware of it are not happy about it
and Donald Trump position on immigration
resonated with a lot of black people the
other thing about about Donald Trump
that I think in general not just black
people is appealing to me anyway and I'm
not quite sure why some of my fellow
Republicans are so adamantly opposed to
Donald Trump this guy Dave can self-fund
he doesn't need your money Donald Trump
was at a group called the Republican
Jewish coalition and he was asked a
question about does he feel that
Jerusalem should be the undivided
capital of Israel his answer is not
important and he said something like I'm
not sure I haven't thought it through
and he got booed and Donald Trump looked
up and he said I don't need your money
now there's a guy named Nelson
Sheldon Adelson in Las Vegas he's a
multi-billionaire alas
election cycle he gave Newt Gingrich 10
mils a lot of a lot of people feel that
but for that Newt Gingrich's attack on
Mitt Romney and all the footage that he
gave Democrats to use in the general
election Romney might have won that's
not the point the point is he is a
kingmaker and right now he is trying to
decide whether he wants to give money to
Ted Cruz or to Marco Rubio he has lost
Vegas business interests I'm not mad at
him for doing something to pursue his
interests but the point is he expect his
phone call to return to be returned
Donald Trump can say screw you to all
these people the people they get
subsidies for milk the people that get
suffer these for sugar the people they
get subsidies for this ridiculous
product known as ethanol the unions that
keep Amtrak running Donald Trump does
not need their money he does not have to
take their phone call
so what guy can really do what should be
done for the American people which is to
get all the crony capitalism and all
these so-called special interests out of
our government and get it down to the
size that ought to be Boeing gets money
from the government Google gets money
from the government Dutch royal gets
money from the government this is
corporate welfare and the reason happens
is because they give contribution to the
politicians who in turn then do their
bidding Donald Trump does not need their
money he is in a position they downsize
the government in a way unlike any other
politician I've ever seen yeah so
there's I mean there's a lot of irony
there it's you've what you're really
talking about is that's truly systemic
political tell me roblem tell me about
it polity so that's and that's half that
should unite everybody across the board
sure that stuff our sister should I mean
right now la is gonna get to team two
football teams probably yeah Oakland and
San Diego and st. Louis are all vying to
come out here by the way all three of
them used to play here the rams used to
play here okay play here and the first
LA Chargers one of the AFL teams started
here and they move to Sandhya now they I
want to come back why because their
respective cities won't give them
hundreds of billions of dollars in tax
subsidies
why should a multi-billionaire get
millions of dollars from taxpayers who
then in turn have to pay all this to go
to the game and watch multi-millionaire
ballplayers it's right be yeah well
that's like City corporate welfare
that's a city's disgusting City field
where the Mets play in New York
you know that it was funded by partly by
taxpayer money I mean while the
government's bailing out citibank who
has their name whole thing is reduced so
the Trump thing real quick one of the
things is in the first debate the first
Republican debate about three months ago
now
I thought the unmasking that he did was
actually kind of amazing even though I
disagree with him on pretty much
everything but you know when they asked
him about going to Hillary's daughter's
wedding right Elsie's wedding and he was
like yeah I give him money buddy I'm a
business guy I got it you know I got to
do what I got to do so in a weird way
even if you don't like so for my for my
liberal friends and my friends I left
even if you hate the messaging and you
know all the Muslims stuff and all that
even if you hate all that the unmasking
of the system and that's why I've also
talked about how Bernie and Trump have a
lot in common because the core of what
they're doing is the biggest threat to
the system right Bernie and and Trump
have a lot in common in the sense that
the establishment is scared to death of
both of them but Bernie will make things
worse taking over large corporations
will make things worse raising taxes on
job creators will make things worse what
Donald Trump wants to do I will make
things better hmm all right well I
barely got to any of the questions there
which is a testament to you so I'm glad
we got to sit down so let me end this
thing and a little bit of the future
where do you think this country is going
in the next year do you so I sense are
you supporting Trump I haven't taken a
position on anybody yet yeah so I will
support whoever the nominee is over
Hillary Clinton or Bernie Sanders
certainly yeah
do you Hillary and Bernie both sort of
as equally yeah equally is equally bad I
mean I mean when you when you've asked
Hillary to give the difference as Chris
Matthews recently did between a Democrat
and a socialist she couldn't do it
Debbie wasserman-schultz the chairwoman
of the DNC was asked the same question
she couldn't do it
and Hillary has gone further to the left
because she's threatened by Bernie
Sanders she's now come out by talking
about a surcharge tax on on on
millionaires she didn't do that before
and she's also coming out on the left
now and gun she didn't to do that before
so Bernie's pushed her to the left so as
far as I'm concerned their positions are
pretty much indistinguishable yeah and
again this may go to show why the system
is just broken because both sides in the
primary process have to stake out these
positions that they know
that they're not going to govern by
right Richard Nixon used to say when you
want to win presidency in the primary
you run to the right and then when you
run in the general election you run to
the center that's kind of how it works
in the primary season you have to run to
your base and then kind of run to the
center to try and trying to get
independence yeah how it works yeah all
right well listen I've thoroughly
enjoyed talking to you I didn't expect
we were going to agree on everything we
didn't that's fine maybe I learned a
little something here maybe you learned
a little so I see a glimmer in your so
if you move a little bit towards the
center well I consider myself as a
classical liberal I don't I don't
consider myself off the deep end left
and maybe I just I think in general a
lot of people on the left are starting
to realize how do you feel about voters
I think we should have vouchers I think
you should have access to God how do you
feel about affirmative action how do you
feel about giving a black person or a
brown person additional points just
because they're black and brown over
some equally qualified white person are
you happy with that
unhappy don't care oh man now I'm being
interviewed all right so yeah I would
say that I think at some time at some
point in America there was a reason that
it really did make sense because they
because some of the more systemic stuff
still exists today and today it probably
doesn't make as much sense anymore
I think you would agree with me on that
because that's pretty much what you
don't think it ever made any but that's
but that's exactly why I want to have
these conversations and why especially I
think that that liberals and
libertarians should realize that we're
sort of in the center together and that
there's a way to there's a way to work
together so that's exactly what I wanted
to do this fair enough
so all right so I thank my guest Larry
elder you can check out clips of the
larry elder show and more Larry's work
at larry elder calm